courbet 1882 il arrive sur rtl
non il serait en partance vers le groupe
m6 c'est l'heure d'une nouvelle enquête
de baba et on se dira tout juste après
mon juge c'est parti lui c'est frédéric
courbet plus connu sous le nom de julien
courbet voilà déjà quatre ans que la
seule personne au monde qui supporte les
girondins de bordeaux est arrivé sur
s'est vite sur la plus grande chaîne
d'europe julien courbet rejointe entre
autres touche pas à mon poste où il
réussit à imposer son élégance et son
sens de l'analyse
[Musique]
sur ces 8 tout lui réussit il décide
alors de lancer un concours de barbecue
et paradoxalement ce barbecue sera
four mais depuis septembre julien
courbet est à la tête d'une quotidienne
à succès dans laquelle il est notamment
entouré de jean michel cohen le
nutritionniste n'y a plus de poids à
perdre que ces patients est ce assez
unique en neuf mois c'est que de la télé
n'a cessé de faire de l'audience et le
buzz
mais ce lundi à 12h23 la nouvelle tombe
julien courbet keats et 8 pour m6 et w9
il laisserait l'amuseur public cyril
hanouna sur le carreau julien courbet a
donc décidé de s'échapper tel un saint
de tatiana laurens
alors julien courbet at il raison de
rejoint le groupe m6 va-t-il remplacer
stéphane plaza est présentée recherche
fenêtre ouverte à que va-t-il advenir de
cédric 6r l'un des plus grands futurs
talents de la télévision française qui
officie à ses côtés et je ne dis pas ça
parce que c'est moi et surtout quelqu'un
va-t-il enfin nous dire pourquoi ça
s'appelle c'est que de la télé alors que
ça ne parle jamais de télé
autant de questions auxquelles
inspecteurs baba va tenter de répondre
on va répondre à toutes ces questions
avec noah commence juste après google
games et jowood legros et le grand héros
qui va venir nous voir offrir un instant
il ya plein de choses dans cette
émission julien donc julien courbet il
ya des tweets qui sont tombés ce matin
julien courbet sur en partance pour m6
il ya eu ensuite un article de pure
médias et de jean marc morandini qui ont
relayé cette info vous travaillez
actuellement sur rtn qui appartient au
groupe m6 c'est parce que m6 maintenant
à racheter en plus certes elle donc ça y
est c'est le même groupe
vous êtes arrivé en 2014 sur ces 8 vous
avez présenté plusieurs jeux le maillon
faible
à prendre ou à laisser still standing
vous avez présenté donc c'est que de la
télé vous avez présenté des prime vous
étiez vous avez présenté le vendredi
tpm paix et julien courbet après on va
voir ce que vous allez faire dans le
groupe m6 ou sur w9
mais julien donc est-ce que vous pouvez
nous confirmer on va le dire un coup
parti de ces vite
aujourd'hui je vous le confirme que
j'arrêterai en même temps que vous le 13
ou le 14 le 14 mai si tu veux qu'on te
fasse bien vous 14 et voilà que c'était
une décision super difficile à prendre
et je tiens mais vraiment vraiment à
dire que on ne part pas parce qu'il ya
un problème on part parce qu'à d'autres
raisons je n'ai aucun problème avec 6,8
ce n'est pas une question de gpu ce que
je voulais il ya d'ailleurs pas une
négociation ou même effet une
proposition qui était très sympa vous la
donnerais si vous avez envie mais moi je
la garde pour moi ça va je leur lance
tout oui je pars tout simplement parce
que c'était logique
ma ma vie construite autour d'air t elle
ses affaires 20 ans que je suis sur
cette radio et j'ai quand même un beau
succès sur rtl moi j'ai douze ya
beaucoup de gens qui m'écoutent est la
radio alors ça marche bien c'est que de
la télé mais c'est que de la télé ces
cinq cent mille donc je ne peux pas
négliger rtl qui est un très gros succès
et quand m6 rachète airtel et qu'il
m'appelle en me disant oh ben non il
faut re signer son contrat avec rtl mes
vieux on aimerait bien que tu vas bien
violemment parce que oui et que tu viens
avec nous parce qu'on va faire des
synergies parce que ça sera plus facile
de parler des émissions de m6 w9 sur rtl
et ça sera plus facile de parler d' rtl
sur doublé n'est pas ce qu'on veut faire
des trucs ensemble
jérôme batx mois avec m6 actuellement je
suis dans les locaux de m6 je croise m6
tout le temps ça m'a paru logique
d'aller là bas et en plus
abel heureusement je peux pas vous en
dire beaucoup plus c'était un petit
virage en animation pour des trucs vous
allez voir un peu un peu différent alors
julien voilà pas se mentir ou on le
savait je vous le dis je vous appeler
pour vous le dire c'est qu'elle vaut
mieux le savoir blekte cgt la première
personne que julien rappelé mme yade
deux heures je vous le dis donc je suis
bien
moi j'ai franchement je voulais
absolument que tu restes le sais parce
que je trouve vraiment qu'on rigole tous
les deux voilà on s'est marré ça fait
combien de temps maintenant que tu es
avec nous ça fait cinq ans était avec
nous sur la chaîne et voilà je voulais
te dire moi en tout cas je te souhaite
vraiment utile c'est beaucoup beaucoup
de bonheur sur m6 j'ai eu le patron de
m6 nicolas de tavernot tout à l'heure
voilà accueilli ses besoins dont celle
par sms est vraiment ils ont été encore
très classe voilà m6 et w9 est ce que
c'est vrai que le patron de m6 et a dit
si tu viens pas dans groupe m6 avec qui
réplique et donc continuer à ce point
ses parents à se prononcer non non non
il n'y a pas eu de pression comme ça il
ya juste que il a dit ça me paraîtrait
logique en plus c'est anecdotique en
fait ça fait quand même 40 balais que je
supporte les girondins de bordeaux ça
apporte et m6
je suis animateur l'un des animateurs
principaux d'airtel sa partie m6 et
surtout la chaîne touchera des émissions
que j'ai conçu dans ma vie sont dans
l'univers des miss les émissions de
coaching passer ma démission
c'est la plainte qui aurait pu paraître
le grand frère ou pas non le grand froid
j'ai aucune on n'a pas parlé avec lui il
est temps ils sont en mongolie les
tournois il est parti avec quatre ados
ils s'entendent en ce moment alors ce
que vous avez des questions est ce que
vous comprenez le choix de julien et
après julien tu nous diras un dernier
mot oui julien courbet vous m'avez
beaucoup déçu
mais toi tu es là ce soir c'est le
summum franchement vous n'étiez pas bien
là il y avait plein de choses et a dit
qu'il était bien que ça a été compliqué
j'aurai une dernière question à se poser
des mots sur ce que c'est le choix de
l'argent
ah non alors là certainement pas mais
alors vraiment parce que j'ai encore une
fois j'avais une quotidienne ici donc
une quotidienne mais comme le son nom
l'indiqué ça rapporte beaucoup plus
cyril m'a proposé plein de choses mais
alors absolument pas et de toutes façons
tout au long de ma carrière quand je
suis parti tf1 france 2 c'était pour
perdre la moitié
là je vais pas perdre la moitié mais pas
vous mentir mais ce n'était pas du tout
une question d'argent absolument pas